[Applaudissements]
j'avais revu ces images là j'imagine pas
la première fois depuis quelques jours
là ça faisait 20 ans vendredi jour pour
jour c'est dans la colonne des très
bonnes journées
oui c'était une bonne journée mais pas
en même temps c'est une journée mais ça
a été précédé de presque 50 travail
acharné à faire la tournée des régions
des consultations on était bien préparé
et on avait lancé monsieur roi notre
programme électoral un an avant ce qui
était sans précédent aussi qui était
très détaillé je l'ai tout relu
dernièrement et ça me rappelle à quel
point nous nous étions effectivement
très bien préparée 10 ans de pouvoir on
va y revenir mais d'abord l'autre
victoire ressemble que vous avez
remporté c'est en cours supérieur contre
l'UPAC qui condamne le gouvernement du
Québec à vous verser 385000 dollars
parce que les fuites ont causé des torts
irréparables disiez vous comment vous
avez reçu cette victoire là est-ce que
c'est la fin de l'exercice où il y en
aura d'autres
je ne voulais pas aller en cours moi je
vais demander au gouvernement des
excuses et j'aurais été satisfait de
recevoir des excuses pour avoir via des
ma vie privée mais ils ont refusé j'ai
été forcé d'aller devant le tribunal à
regret et le jugement j'invite les gens
à lire ça fait 26 pages je suis très
clair de et dénonce le fait que le pack
a tout un pratique s'est fait un système
de justice parallèle à celui qui existe
et il est vraiment en question des
institutions et ça a été très dur parce
que ils ont systématiquement violé ma
vie privée celle de d'autres personnes
alors c'est avec un sentiment de regret
que je suis allé en cours puis les gens
qui ont fait ça monsieur Roy qui ont été
placés devant ces choix-là ou diront
toujours que s'ils avaient pu éviter le
tribunal même quand on gagne on évite
parce que c'est tellement lourd à porter
c'est un chemin de croix mais vous avez
gagné
s'il y avait des excuses qui venaient de
Monsieur Lego qui n'a pas exclu des
excuses la semaine dernière ou l'autre
semaine avant est-ce que vous allez de
l'avant parce que là vous le juge vous
invite reports à continuer pour
procédure abusé voilà c'est un petit peu
compliqué d'abord dans la même poursuite
on a fait notre requête spéciale pour
abus de procédure c'est exceptionnel un
abus c'est quand il y a une des parties
qui abuse de sa position pour forcer
l'autre à engager des dépenses ou à
faire des choses que n'aurait pas dû
normalement être obligé de faire et le
juge en présente la requête au juge le
juge dit je dois vous entendre oui ou
non c'est la première étape et là il y a
du oui je vais vous entendre là-dessus
alors donc ça c'est une prochaine étape
qui va se faire pas nouveau c'est dans
le jugement puis on va donner plus ne
pas donner suite là vous allez donner
suite on va donner suite on va donner
suite parce qu'on l'avait demandé et on
va demander au juge de nous attendre
là-dessus et ça ça va alors je
commencerai pas là dessus je dois
respecter la démarche du tribunal mais
on va déposer une on va ça va se plaider
je pense ensemble je pense que ça se
plaidera même pas dans une salle de
cours mais devant le juge est-ce que
malgré cette victoire là parce que vous
avez dit si le gouvernement s'est excusé
je serai pas là en cours là vous êtes
allé en cours vous avez gagné est-ce que
ça ça fait pour le gouvernement ils
peuvent faire l'économie de vous
présenter des excuses puisque vous avez
gagné je pense que le gouvernement là on
est dans le domaine on n'est pas dans le
domaine des règles strictes moi je pense
que un gouvernement qui représente
l'état l'État c'est ça transforme des
individus ça transcende qui est au
pouvoir à ce moment-là doit agir de
manière noble et c'est ce que j'ai
toujours essayé de faire moi quand
j'étais au gouvernement et j'étais allé
circonstances je pense que oui il
devrait présenter des excuses puis il y
avait quelqu'un qui disait plus pacte de
représenter des excuses du pack qui lui
reste pas beaucoup de crédibilité mais
ça donc c'est une question qui est
restée ouverte et j'espère que le
gouvernement va poser un geste qui est
noble dans les circonstances
que vous avez créé reniquement
à vos yeux ne devraient plus exister
devrait saisisser ces activités
réintégrer ça ben moi je veux pas entrer
là-dedans j'ai fait c'est au
gouvernement actuel pour Parlement
actuel à des battre de ces questions-là
et d'en faire dans faire prendre une
décision sur l'avenir de l'UPAC je
constate que les problèmes ont continué
jusqu'à 20-21 il y a un procès qui a été
annulé parce que le numéro 2 de l'UPAC
en 2021 c'était par jury devant le
tribunal c'est pas c'est pas de montant
moins c'est pas et c'est pas du temps du
commissaire précédent alors ça c'est des
sujets qui devront débattre puis décider
l'équilibre j'imagine vous avez beaucoup
réfléchi à ça c'est comment arriver pour
un état
à prôner une tolérance zéro pour les
fraudeurs
puis en même temps de pas abuser les
droits des citoyens
l'équilibre il doit être
atteints non surtout pas jamais jamais
en même temps quand le plaider notre
affaire moi le juge le noter j'ai pas
plaider en disant je fais un ancien
Premier ministre donc j'ai même sa même
été le contraire il note d'un jugement
et ça a pas été soulevé puis à poser la
question mais commencer un premier
ministre moi je suis pas au dessus des
lois mais je suis pas en deçà des lois
non plus et donc il faut respecter la
présomption d'innocence il faut
respecter la règle de droit même si
c'est parfois difficile à faire
c'est le minimum qu'on attend de la part
de ceux et celles qui ont la responsa la
dose responsabilité de de d'exécuter ou
pas d'exécuter mais de mettre en œuvre
les lois
samedi monsieur Charest samedi soir il y
avait quelques centaines de libéraux
réunis pour vous accueillir souligner
les 20 ans dont on parlait les 20 ans de
votre accession au pouvoir je rappelle
pour les gens que vous avez gagné deux
autres mandats après vous avez été battu
en 2012
est-ce que vous espérez qu'à partir de
maintenant on va moins parler des
dossiers d'éthique pour votre davantage
parler
d'autres choses de votre bilan la bourse
carbone le font des générations c'est ça
que vous voulez dans le fond là
le jugement ultime vient de l'histoire
et l'histoire qui s'écrira bien bien
après que j'ai quitté ce monde et ça a
été samedi dernier une des plus belles
journées de ma vie il fait trop de dire
ça mais une belle journée on a retrouvé
tous ces gens là des états des plus de
500 personnes
dans un contexte où on était très
heureux de se revoir mais là la décennie
que j'ai fait moi je l'ai fait beaucoup
sur la base d'une volonté d'ouverture et
d'affirmation pour le Québec et j'ai
faire des choses moi qui était long
terme le fond des générations bourse
carbone plein d'or l'ensemble de
libre-échange avec l'Europe l'entente
sur la mobilité de la main d'oeuvre avec
la France qui sans précédent dans le
monde est-ce que ils font des
générations alors ce que je voulais moi
parce que ça fait partie de mon ADN et
d'ailleurs quand j'étais au fédéral je
l'ai fait partie d'un gouvernement pour
qui c'était également le mode
d'opération c'est à dire on fait des
choses en politique qui vont durer bien
au-delà de notre propre vie des vrais
changements seront là mais ces
changements-là monsieur roi sont
difficiles parce que on dépense un
capital politique quand on le fait c'est
tout le contraire du populisme en
passant c'est le tout le contraire j'en
parlais tout à l'heure du populisme dans
l'autre cours vous avez beaucoup joué la
Cour fédérale mais je reviens donc
est-ce que vous trouvez que que
jusqu'ici les Québécois ou en tout cas
ont été injustes
envers vous en
focusant sur les questions d'éthique
contenu de la commission Charles au
compte tenu ça fait beaucoup de bruit
quand même je reconnais qu'il y a une
perception puis dans beaucoup de gens la
perception changera pas malgré ce que
mais en même temps la vérité c'est droit
et le jugement nous rappelle que
ultimement il y a la vérité et c'est
pour ça que les gens je dis aux gens si
pas tout le monde s'intéresse pas tout
le monde mais lisez-le jugement
ultimement la vérité va c'est ça qui va
vaincre la vérité à la tête dure alors à
travers tout ça avec le temps aussi on
voit des choses comme elles sont et je
suis très fier d'avoir fait ce
gouvernement d'ouverture et
d'affirmation de Québec ça a été une
affirmation à l'intérieur du Canada on a
fait le conseil de fédération ça dure
encore on a fait des changements qui ont
permis au Québec de s'affirmer puis de
grandir et c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai toujours voulu regrets monsieur
Charret je vais vous demander vous en
avez une numérique quelques-uns de vos
bons coups d'après vous mais regrets
dans ces trois mandats des choses que
vous avez échappées bah il y a des il y
a des volonté très forte de réduire les
impôts et ça on s'était beaucoup avancé
là-dessus et sincèrement on n'a pas
cherché à quand on a fait notre code
financier en 2002 un an avant on l'avait
fait vérifier par des économistes mais
quand je suis arrivé au gouvernement on
s'est buté à des choses qu'on n'avait
pas vu venir par exemple le fédéral nous
demande erreur pour se mettre 2,6
milliards parce qu'il y avait un trop
payé il y avait alors ça nous a pris du
temps à arriver une réduction d'impôts
on est arrivé on a réussi à réduire les
impôts qu'on a réussi à augmenter le
revenu disponible mais sur les impôts
j'aurais voulu aller plus loin plus vite
parce qu'à mon avis il y avait besoin
pour le Québec de retrouver davantage
d'oxygène sur le plan fiscal on est
arrivé à des résultats dans les
Québécois quand j'ai quitté le pouvoir
en 2012 j'étais plus riche que en 2003
le revenu a augmenté et en une forte
réduction de la pauvreté ce dont nous
sommes très fiers parce que ça ça a été
ça c'est significatif entre autres pour
les familles monoparentales les
étudiants par contre étaient dans la rue
étant maudit contre vous et votre
gouvernement le printemps érable est-ce
que ça avec le recul parce que les
années ont passé vous dites on aurait dû
mieux saisir l'air du temps le voyage on
aurait dû mieux saisir que il y a
quelque chose qui se passait dans ce
mouvement là il y avait dedans à faire
de conviction pour moi parce que quand
je dis ouverture affirmation le Québec
peut réussir que la condition d'avoir un
système d'éducation qui est vraiment
calé de mondial faut vraiment qu'on soit
permis les meilleurs puis c'est ça la
politique on l'avait une chose qu'on a
pas fonctionné comme prévu on l'a pas vu
venir nous cette mouvement de
contestation là parce que la politique
après de longues consultations avec été
livré un an avant puis là un an plus
tard on se retrouve devant une
contestation qui a pris une ampleur
j'ai vu que ça c'est là peut-être qu'il
y aurait pu avoir quelque chose
mais là on est arrivé à la fin de notre
mandat on est allé en érection mais pour
moi il y avait la dame sur One a fait de
conviction profonde puis j'y crois
toujours je suis allé jusqu'au bout de
mes convictions bon
vous dites c'est un des plus beaux jours
de votre vie samedi mais quand même le
PLQ plus boxat tumeur ou presque ça
devient le parti des anglophones le
parti des anglophones est-ce que vous
pensiez voir ça de votre vivant le PLQ
si bas j'ai non c'est pas ce genre de
situation là mais j'en ai vécu d'autres
rappelez-vous j'ai été chef de députés à
la Chambre des communes puis le Parti
conservateur est revenu on est passé de
2 à 20 alors donc j'ai vu j'avais vécu
dans une autre vie dans des
circonstances différentes
débattles et l'autre partie libérale du
Québec un gros travail à faire de
reconstruction mais une des une des
choses auxquelles je crois profondément
et ça je le dis peu importe les
allégeances politiques qui est très
important que le Parti libéral du Québec
se reconstruise et devienne un choix
pour les Québécois peu importe vos
allégeances politiques nous vivons en
démocratie vous avez vous comme citoyen
le droit d'avoir un choix un bon choix
c'est de faire en sorte que le PQ soit
construise puis je pense qu'ils ont ce
qu'il faut maintenant il faut se mettre
au travail il faut que ce qu'il faut ils
ont pas de chef personne qui veut être
est-ce que vous vous devriez faire un
beau rachat de vous-même de revenir sans
qu'on a joué la nation là vous et moi
l'an dernier
je pense qu'on compris que c'est fini la
politique et donc il y a une nouvelle
génération on doit maintenant prendre la
relève elle est là elle est là la
nouvelle génération mais votre fils
d'ailleurs
écoute pas on va faire une syncope ils
m'ont Office est plus brillant que moi
mais j'ai été chanceux j'ai eu trois
enfants qui m'ont beaucoup secondé et
une épouse qui a été absolument
formidable dans ma carrière politique ce
Charin vous venez de le dire la dernière
fois qu'on s'est parlé vous étiez
candidat à la chefferie du Parti
conservateur du Canada est-ce que
Monsieur Poirier peut dans votre esprit
remporter la prochaine campagne
électorale s'il continue à attaquer
comme là sibici depuis quelques jours
est-ce que c'est pas important des
méthodes américaines qui ne fonctionnent
pas ici Monsieur paulier peut gagner la
prochaine élection générale monsieur
pollièvre bénéficier du fait que
Monsieur Trudeau est au gouvernement
depuis un certain nombre d'années puis
que naturellement il y a un cycle dans
la vie politique maintenant monsieur
polliet à mon avis puis moi je l'avais
fait il y avait 20 ans d'ailleurs le
timing est bon il y a 20 ans un an avant
l'élection on lance un programme très
détaillé ça voulait relisez-le c'est
très détaillé sur ce que nous allons
faire et Monsieur pollièvre doit lui
aussi dire aux Canadiens ce qu'elle est
en son fait pas juste critiquer et ça
c'est
c'est le minimum en termes de démocratie
c'est de dire voici ce que je propose et
pendant la course au leadership vous
rappelez
une des raisons pour lesquelles je suis
allé parce que je m'inquiète l'avenir du
Canada je pense qu'on est bien en deçà
de notre potentiel qui est les partis
politiques fédéraux leur job c'est de
garder le pays unique il fait un machin
ensemble et c'est ce que nous attendons
de Monsieur polyèvre et de tous les
partis politiques fédéraux et populistes
américains pour le Canada c'est pas
notre truc à nous puis ce serait à mon
avis extrêmement mauvais pour nous et
moi j'y crois pas du tout à ce qui j'ai
du respect de nos amis américains mais
le populisme à l'américaine chez nous à
mon avis c'est exactement le contraire
mais ce qui nous attaquer CBC en
essayant de préserver Radio-Canada en
passant mais attaquer si bien ici est-ce
que c'est du populisme américain dans
votre esprit c'est du populisme ça c'est
sûr
bah je sais pas ça là je peux vous dire
une chose pendant la course du
leadership monsieur polieb soulevait ça
dans ses rassemblements il y avait des
applaudissements les gens que de le voir
ils soutenaient sur ça c'est très
probablement
il faut qu'il propose de nouvelles idées
et moi moi Radio-Canada j'y crois que
vous savez à quel point Radio-Canada m'a
beaucoup secondaire dans ma carrière
politique
vous aimez ça quand les questions du
temps mais vous êtes vous êtes un boxeur
vous êtes capable de prendre vous là
vous faites
mais vous avez toujours été là pour
répondre j'y crois Radio-Canada très
bien j'y crois
jeancherai bonne suite on vous souhaite
de continuer dans le privé donc même pas
la petite tentation de rien
merci beaucoup merci au revoir